Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie Super Bowl hype
so there's a whole bunch of trailers stuff
is coming in.
They confirmed that they're making a miles
morales movie.
Some explain what's going on there is a new
round of the Spider-Man giveaway going on
now it's a $20 comixology giftcard.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
This is so great, if you guys forgot the Super
Bowl is coming up, really soon.
So number 10 new trailers Sony has a history
of buying Super Bowl spots for it's Spider-Man
movies, which are typically been summer movies
usually what they do is a buy like 1 30sec
spot will air during the Super Bowl and then
I'll post something longer online.
If you wonder why there's so sure it is because
the price of buying that airtime for an advertisement
which is what the trailer is is basically
an ad for the movie is astronomical is the
most expensive as you could possibly by something
during the Super Bowl.
So those tend to be really short, but it's
a lot cheaper for them to just post stuff
online.
So whatever ends up dropping I'll do a video
for along with that you know number nine Marvel
might also choose to do a guardians of the
galaxy Super Bowl trailer because that's coming
out ways sooner than Spider-Man homecoming
Marvel is been a lot cheaper the way it spends
money on stuff like that.
So last year there was a bunch of Super Bowl
Captain America Civil War stuff the pry be
some similar guardian stuff but maybe not
quite as much, even if it doesn't drop during
the Super Bowl will be posting stuff online.
Just so many people that are paying attention
to what's happening online during that weekend
that everybody tries to get in on the action.
So that's why everybody makes such a big deal
about Super Bowl trailer's number eight though
the miles morale of snooze so they just confirmed
that he's going to get his own stand-alone
movie.
They didn't say how Peter Parker's going to
be involved or what characters though use,
but the people that are writing it or the
people that did the Lego movie that are doing
the upcoming Han Solo movie.
So I am already on board is gonna be awesome.
The press release just said that it's going
to be a lot of fun, and it will coexist with
the live-action universe they're talking about
the MCU in the Spider-Man films so that doesn't
explain a whole lot but just in the name of
logic and insanity you can pick a couple things
out of that soak most of you probably already
know all about the character's origins.
You have to imagine that a lot of people have
no idea who he is.
So if you were a rollup in a Spider-Man costume
they be like why is Spider-Man's costume different,
so whatever they do with the story the way
they market the movie, it will all be to help
people understand and go see it because it
will be like a big Sony animated feature,
so number seven what it seems like they're
doing is just pretending like it's its own
thing off by itself.
Even though all the crate is the same with
the MCU people because it's animated they
can do whatever they want they can get way
crazier but is not like they're keeping out
on the live-action films they spent $250 million
making Captain America Civil War that whole
airport battle scene was mostly done in a
computer.
That's how much money they spent on that but
animation is just a lot easier.
They have a lot more control over it in the
name of sanity the probably choose to do different
villains though.
So the good thing about miles morales though
is that he has pretty much the same group
of villains that Peter Parker had but it's
the ultimate's universe but they all looked
just a little bit different.
Even though it's the same basic people, but
number six, just because this is like a brand-new
thing in the character's and is well known
as Peter Parker.
They will probably do an origin story.
Unlike Spider-Man homecoming were he's already
been Spider-Man for little while.
So the very first big arc that miles morales
had was ultimate Spider-Man volume 2 you can
ask to go read if you want but basically what
happened is is Peter Parker in the ultimate
universe it died in an a much younger high
school age miles morales had looked up to
him and was bitten by a radioactive spider
just like Peter Parker was he got powers.
So be to because Peter fallen he admired them
so much he took the mantle to honor him, but
during his first adventure he gets his ass
holes into the shield by spider woman saying
who the hell are you in the Spider-Man costume.
So all of Peter's friends were just like what
the hell is going on with this kid.
Where did you get your powers, where did you
come from, but the nearby in a separate cell
electro goes haywire starts attacking all
the heroes miles helps take him down so then
they start to trust them.
He goes back to his family and the rest of
his early art just coming to terms with who
his family as he has criminals in his family.
His uncle is the prowler responsible for the
spider bite they gave him powers in the first
place and is just trying to be a kid.
So it's kind of like was happening in the
Spider-Man homecoming movie.
So you have a brand-new Spider-Man who still
in high school is trying to figure things
out and still be a kid and hang out with his
friends at the same time in the funny thing
is is a lot of you have noticed that Spider-Man
homecoming has borrowed a lot of elements
from the miles morales comic book, so his
best friend is net leads he looks exactly
like miles morales his best friend Genki who
is a completely different character.
So number five what the probably do is just
adapt some of that initial origin story run
for miles morales maybe swap in a couple different
characters just as they don't end up doing
the exact same people as the Spider-Man homecoming
movie but I am expecting though is that the
animated marvel universe will aesthetically
look very similar to the live-action universe
is still New York City.
So you know what New York City looks like
in the live-action universe, but just like
the Netflix shows you go to different parts
of New York City.
They all feel very different all the Netflix
shows have a very different tone.
So I'm expecting the Spider-Man homecoming
movie to be the same thing like it'll be Spider-Man
it will still be very familiar but it'll also
have a slightly different tone.
Even though you're in and around the same
area.
Speaking of which number four they said it
can be a lot of fun.
I think that definitely means that they will
not kill Peter Parker to create miles morales
so that will be like a slight change from
the comic book origin story.
Just think about how much of a bummer.
Note that would be to start on we have a bunch
little kids that just got done seeing Tom
Holland in Avengers infinity war and they
see this opening scroll explaining how.
Spider-Man is dead and he's never coming back.
It just so many people which is bail it would
be the worst thing ever.
So with the probably do is the find a way
to include the Peter Parker character but
he will be older the whole idea is that miles
morales is the little kid learning to be Spider-Man
superhero will Peter Parker, is this battle
hardened version of the character and I know
I name dropped infinity war.
They haven't confirmed.
When this new movie is going to be released
but it'll probably be sometime in the next
year to just depending on how long it takes
to finish the animation.
So I think that'll drop sometime after infinity
war so you'll already seen Tom Holland in
three big movies number three, what about
villains though who will be the big villain
like I said is the ultimate universe the is
all the same characters they would probably
just opt to do ultimate green goblin do Norman
Osborne even though when miles morales the
story gets started in the comics he's kind
of in prison, but it seems like the Spider-Man
homecoming movie is not gonna do green goblin
for a long long time.
So you want to go with the big villain that
you recognize green goblin is the solid pick,
but I always get a lot of questions about
this yes I do think that they will do green
goblin in the live-action movies eventually
there's gonna be three Tom Holland Spider-Man
homecoming movies I think will definitely
get to him eventually but they're going to
take their time we were ready scene two versions
of Norman Osborne in the last iterations of
Spider-Man.
So I don't think they want to go there right
away with this brand-new version of the character,
but number two because it's animation they
can actually borrow actors from the live-action
universe, so they haven't confirmed anything
about whose can be playing who they haven't
cast miles morales yet but they could totally
bring Donald Glover back.
I don't think that he would play miles morales
just because he's a little bit older their
plight cast a little kid to do the voice and
speaking of awesome.
Spider-Man fax did you know that it was the
Russo's of Captain America Civil War told
Dan Harmon to cast Donald Glover way way back.
For season one of community before he blew
up and became a big store.
So it all comes back around now Donald Glover's
in the MCU even though is not being directed
by the Russo's but it is funny how things
work out that way.
So what about the avengers though like what
they actually have Avengers from the live-action
movies voice their roles in the animated movie
they could do that but I don't think that
they will and I think will try to keep it
as simple as possible.
Even though the avengers in all the big characters
will exist in the animated universe, so the
probably find a way to include them without
doing it in a way that's gonna confuse everyone,
that's also seeing infinity war that same
year where it's like hey get all these characters
are here.
How can they also be often infinity war doing
all this other stuff but will find a really
simple way around that.
But number one sequels.
So if this first one is successful you can
expect a miles morales standalone franchise
it also sort of like lives with the Tom Holland
franchise without stepping on his toes too
much, but even though they haven't said what
the title is going to be.
I'm just expecting them to call it ultimate
Spider-Man.
It is though simple thing ever.
But they could choose to go with a different
subtitle let me know in the comments what
you guys think about miles morales which characters
do you want them to use which story arc.
Do you want them to adapt and what you want
them to call the movie if you like ultimate
Spider-Man is just the easiest thing for them
to go with is a whole bunch of stuff happening
next is gonna be a new Logan trailer.
So all totally do a video for that I'll say
congratulations to the new Spider-Man giveaway
winner honored you and a $20 comics all and
she giftcard please private message me on
the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details still turned slowly hypnotize
people into reading more comic books.
So new Logan trailer come in and a little
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about Deadpool 2 and
you can click here to rewatch the Injustice
2 trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
five I'll see you guys tonight!